you know we've got coordination where
you know Charles
will have invited every you know
ecologist vegetarian
Anton deck a seat for them both
apparently uh that you can think of but
there's not a seat for every Member of
Parliament the elected house
which I think is a bit much actually I
mean I don't really care as I say
because I'm not a member of palm anymore
but it's a bit strange it also it's
pretty insane I would have thought for
the new king to offend so many members
of the elected house so that's the
situation apparently apart from the
leaders of the political parties
everybody else has got to stick their
their name in a ballot and if you know
if you come out in the raffle then you
get to The Abbey if you get second prize
you get to go in the tent in Victoria
Gardens which I I think it's a very
strange way to to run a coordination but
like hey ho it's up to up to King
Charles